this weekend a stunning new museum opens
on the waterfront in Cape Town South
Africa the Zeitz Museum of Contemporary
African art sites MOCA as it's known is
Africa's first Modern Art Museum and
houses 80 galleries Debora patta reports
now on the breathtaking structure that
is viewed as groundbreaking by some but
as elitist by others from its glittering
opening in Cape Town - it's jaw-dropping
atrium and even a special blessing by
Nobel laureate Archbishop Desmond Tutu
there is nothing ordinary about the
sights at MOCA bringing together artists
from across Africa it is the continents
first contemporary African art museum
British architect Thomas Heather wick
has transformed the city's nearly 100
year old grain silo complex into an
awe-inspiring concrete cave-like
architectural wonder if you knock it
down and just build a spaceship that
feels like it's landed from somewhere
else in the world there was a risk that
people would come look at the outside
take a photograph of himself buy a
postcard and go home and say they saw
the museum so we got interested in how
you could make the inside a super
memorable thing and memorable it is
instead of destroying the structure
Heather we cut through the silos
inspired by the building's original
purpose grain storage we found that
there was still a little store of some
of the original corn that had been
stored in the building and we got one of
those grains of corn and we digitally
scanned it so we had the exact shape and
enlarged it to be ten stories high and
that's what you see here artist Artie
Pedro Regas work has never been
displayed in a museum before this one is
the first time it actually is going to
be seen by the public and I'm quite
excited having feel about that I mean
here's your art and he cannot forget
that just over two decades ago black
South Africans were not allowed into art
galleries in
there is that memory when it comes to
architecture in public spaces here in
South Africa there is an invisible for
whites only sign so I feel that a new
building that is it is like literally
carved from the past somehow has a
democracy in it whilst the museum has
opened up exciting possibilities for
African artists it has also raised some
contentious issues Cape Town is often
seen as a playground for wealthy locals
and international visitors so the
decision to locate the museum here at
the waterfront a popular tourist
attraction has been met with some
criticism the odd walls like everything
else in South Africa we need to kind of
be cognizant of the fact that like
everything else had happened along
racial lines and then those remnants are
still away right now art historian dr.
Simon Blue League is painfully aware of
the fact that even though the museum
might be free for a couple of hours a
week it is located miles away from poor
black communities if you're building a
museum that isn't in an area where that
is not necessarily accessible to people
of a certain class in a certain race
then their questions they are
uncomfortable questions but the museum
has really answered saying education
will be key starting with plans to
regularly bus in school children my
passion is the public experience the
experience we share to get there not
because private homes
private realms and private galleries
here the weak believes this is the start
of transforming the art world in Africa
into a space that is no longer just for
a privileged elite for CBS this morning
Saturday Debora patta Cape Town South
Africa wow it's such an interesting
issue this whole the art accessible to
the public Heather what does some
amazing work and it's coming he's doing
it around the world it's real it's art
housed in art and you just hope they
follow through with this idea of
bringing in and busing in so that you
can have the education